there's a good book that I would
recommend reading called the great
leveler by Walter shy del it's a new
book relatively new book and he details
out the he details out the in erotic
ability of inequality so part of the
problem with this process that we just
described where success breeds success
and failure breeds failure is that the
people who are succeeding get a
disproportionate share of the resource
pie
let's say so and you know everyone knows
that about money right because the
twelve richest people in the world 85
richest people in the world have as much
money as the bottom 2 billion which
seems well let's say unfair now it's
certainly unequal now whether I believe
Lord in your statistic is the eighth
richest have equal to the bottom 3.5
billion yeah well it's probably worse
than it was when I looked at this about
three years ago so but it doesn't it
doesn't matter because you get the point
but it's um it's not crazy but the thing
is is that this is not something that
only applies to money it applies to
everything that's creatively produced
so the same rule applies to number of
records sold by recording artists the
same rule applies to number of books
sold by novelists the same rule applies
to number of goals scored by NHL hockey
players the same rule applies to the
population of cities and the mass of
stars and the size of trees in the in
the jungle it's like the inequality
problem is way more troublesome again
than mere capitalism it's a terrible
problem and shy Dells work which is
really really interesting he's traced
back inequality ten fifteen thousand
years using you can do it for example
let's say you find a Neolithic burial
site and there's two hundred people in
it so these people would be buried with
their possessions and obviously some of
them decay but some of them don't and
like some of them are buried with gold
well hardly any of them and the tiny
proportion of people who are buried with
gold are buried with a lot of gold so
you can even derive a Gini coefficient
estimate which is an estimate of
inequality from burial sites and it
looks like as soon as you get a surplus
you get inequality and that's a rough
thing eh because you might think well
even in hunter-gatherer societies where
there's no surplus there's still
inequality because there's inequality of
friendship there's inequality of health
and there's inequality of sexual access
and those things are they are not
trivial
but when you're thinking about it purely
economically you start to get an
inequality as soon as you get a surplus
you think oh that's interesting so
there's a natural rule which is surplus
generates inequality alright so how do
you solve that and shy Dells book says
well that's easy
you just get rid of the surplus
right and that's not good so like he
found and so one of the things he did
with statistical analysis because one of
the things he might ask is well let's
say you have your measures of inequality
and then you can track them around the
world and you can track whether or not
the inequality is generated by a
right-wing government or a left-wing
government and then you might hope well
the left-wing governments would
ameliorate inequality there's no
evidence for that at all it doesn't look
like inequality is with it it doesn't
look like the amelioration of inequality
is within the purview of political
organization and you'd like you should
not hear that with any degree of
happiness whatsoever because the social
science on inequality is also clear as
inequality levels increase societies
destabilize and the best indicator of
that I already mentioned that that was
work that was done by Martin Daly and
Margot Wilson at McMaster University in
Canada they're really interested in what
drove male homicide because most
homicide is male male-on-male it's
mostly young males it's mostly within
race and it's mostly status competition
right so and the status competitions get
intense where inequality increases so
where everyone's poor so if you rank
order American States and Canadian
provinces by inequality the poorer
provinces where everyone's poor there's
no male aggression and the rich
provinces and states where everyone's
rich there's no male it male homicide
but the states and provinces where
inequality is high the male homicide
rate starts to climb up and it's
probably the most aggressive males who
get most aggressive most rapidly when
inequality increases so there's a
psychological component but inequality
drives male homicide 0.9 is the
correlation which means that you
actually don't need any other
explanation for male homicide maybe you
throw in alcohol just just as it as an
extraneous variable you don't need any
other explanation for the male homicide
rate than inequality it's a staggering
work it's absolutely staggering work and
so the the thing is
that a meritocracy will drive inequality
and then you have a problem because
people stack up at zero and they can't
get out of zero because that's what
happens as inequality increases people
think about when you're playing Monopoly
you know the game I mean that's a
perfect example of how inequality
emerges everybody is equal to begin with
everybody basically plays a random game
because monopoly is basically a random
game I mean there's some skill in it but
not much so so it's a random game so
what happens when everyone starts equal
and you play a random game one person
ends up with everything everyone else
stacks up at zero
ouch Adele's book basically shows the
only way out of that is various forms of
war including revolution and epidemics
that's if that's the only thing he's
been able to track that and and what
happens is well you level everyone and
then the inequality decreases it's like
well okay like that doesn't seem like a
really great solution